okay all right that's fine time or
normal time
uh i don't know we can wait that's cool
like of all the devices i have the only
one that has a microphone that works
is the super tiny tablet
cool you can see my laser pointer right
yep that's pretty cool
remember oh how do i get rid of it
stuck there forever okay
this is a really unflattering angle
okay guess the number of panelists says
or the number of attendees is kind of uh
participants is kind of stabilized so
you want to get started
okay okay i'll introduce you okay well
uh thank you everyone for joining the
last day of the mathematical and
decision making workshop and uh we'd
like to start off today
by um by inviting our very own akshay
and he is a principal researcher at
microsoft new york
and has a lot of really exciting results
and bandits
and uh as now have recently many very
exciting results in reinforcing learning
so i'm very excited and please take it
away
uh thanks alan and thanks everyone for
coming in west coasters for waking up
kind of early
uh i guess this is the msr new york city
day
of the workshop so i'll just like kick
things off
uh yeah so this is gonna be talk about
representation learning and exploration
and um there's kind of like two stories
around
like why you might be excited in this
problem the first one is like how i got
excited in this problem
and the second one is maybe more how why
other people might be exciting this
problem and i kind of want to tell you
the first one
it's going to be a little bit of like um
you know like a bit of
like i don't know how you say it like a
spotlight of some previous work we've
done and then
it'll have like a broader theme with
what's going on in the in the main
course
um okay so back in 2015 i had just
finished my phd
and i joined msr new york and john
langford i like agarwal and i decided we
wanted to
start learning about reinforcement
learning and uh we read a bunch of stuff
i like
had not worked on it before and we
started trying to understand if we could
develop provably efficient
reinforcement learning algorithms that
scale to like the complex kinds of
domains that you might see in robotics
and gaming and dialogue
and so what we're really trying to do is
use nonlinear function approximation and
address exploration at the same time
and like you know we like thought about
this problem for a while
and i think this is like the first
whiteboard picture i have
from some of our discussions and over
time we slowly started developing
some understanding of what is going on
statistically in some of these problems
this is also with folks like nanjiang
and rob shapiro and one son
and then we started thinking about maybe
an intuitive model
called the block mdp where we're able to
develop some algorithmic results
so i just want to tell you a little bit
about one of these
but first let me tell you what the block
mdp model is so it's a latent state
model
in which uh the agent there's like a
discrete latent state space that governs
the dynamics of the world so you can
think of this like a tabular problem
but the agent does not see the tabular
state instead the agent
is going to see some high dimensional
observation
produced by some emission distribution
associated with each latent state
so the story is that you know maybe
we're considering like a navigation task
and the agent is in a latent state which
is just its xy position something very
very simple
um but the agent doesn't see the xy
position the agent has a camera on its
head
and sees like a image you know of of its
surroundings
and based on its image we'll take an
action
and based on the latent state the
position in the action the you know the
system will transition to a new latent
state and and so it's going to go on
so this is the kind of dynamics model
that we're thinking about and the point
is that the agent operates on you know
these rich observations which could be
like you know extremely complicated
and so you really have to use nonlinear
function approximation here
right we have to use a convolutional
neural net to deal with images or
so you know something complicated has to
go on here but
um you know if you think about this you
know for 30 seconds you'll say oh this
is a
palm dp and i don't want you to consider
it as a pom dp so what i'm going to
assume is that
the latent states are going to be
decodable from the observations which
means that
each latent state is associated with an
emission distribution
over observations and these distinct
distributions one per latent state
actually have disjoint support
and so really this is a markov decision
process on the observation space
but the observation space is is very
complicated
okay so there's there's not going to be
any partial observability and this is
i don't know we haven't really thought
about how to relax this it would be
awesome if we could this is just going
to make our lives a little bit easier
so this is the model we've been thinking
about and we've been able to develop
some algorithms with
some reasonable guarantees i'm just
going to tell you just briefly about one
so this is this algorithm called homer
which is joint work with dependramistra
michael henov and john lankford
and the algorithm is going to interleave
two steps
so one is like uh exploration so it's
going to use some policies to collect
some new data
and the other one is sort of a decoding
step to try to discover what this latent
state space looks like
and the decoding is by a reduction to
supervised learning which is how we can
leverage
like non-linear function approximation
methods and what the algorithm does is
it
it uses like a contrastive learning kind
of objective where it tries to
train a binary classifier to figure out
if transitions like
x a x prime triples are from the real
world like real transitions that could
have occurred in the environment or fake
transitions that
our algorithm is splicing together just
to create negative samples
and so somehow this contrastive
objective is able to discover some
notion of a tabular state space in your
problem and that's going to allow us to
use tabular methods to explore
and that's basically all i want to tell
you about the algorithm i'll tell you
what we prove
so we're going to you know this process
is decodable
so we're going to assume that we have a
class of functions this
capital phi that contains the true
decoder the true mapping from the
observation space
to the latent state space and we're
going to also assume that this class
capital phi doesn't have
like really complex is doesn't have
unbounded statistical complexity
and we're also going to assume that
there is some way to hit every latent
state with reasonable probability
so for every latent state there exists
some policy that gets there with
probability at least
eta and yeah with dependra michael and
john
we're able to show that this algorithm
homer can find a near optimal policy for
this problem
and to cover the state space in a number
of samples that scales polynomially with
the number of latent states the number
of actions
the time horizon one over this
reachability parameter one over
the accuracy parameter and the log
cardinality of the function class
and i guess one thing i want to mention
here is that this log cardinality of
function class is coming just from like
a very standard supervised learning
analysis
so you could replace this with metric
entropy or or other statistical notions
and this is sort of what i mean when i
say i want to be able to
accommodate nonlinear function
approximation any function class for
which you expect
supervised learning to work we should be
able to use in reinforcement learning
and on the computational side this
algorithm we can show it runs in
polynomial time
assuming we can solve certain supervised
learning problems so this is really like
a reduction style of algorithm
where you know i don't really know if i
can train a neural net to convergence
but
if i assume i can do that i can you know
solve this block mvp
and so so you know there's this
computational assumption
that we're making and we need to sort of
verify if this actually makes any sense
so we did implement this algorithm
and we ran it um on like a very hard
combination lock type problem where
there's like 100 time steps and at every
time step there are three latent states
two are good one or bad
and from the two good latent states
there's one action which will advance
you
down the good chain and nine actions
that will advance you to the bad chain
and from the bad chain you're stuck and
you have to stay in a good chain to get
any reward
so if you take random actions in this
problem
um it will take you 10 to the 100
episodes to hit the
hit the reward and obviously we cannot
run for that long
so so we're trying to you know do
something that
you know something non-trivial and uh
also there's some emission distribution
which i'm not going to get into and we
ran a bunch of baselines like
you know standard ppo it doesn't really
have a very good exploration
strategy so it's unsurprising that it
fails
um we also ran this random network
distillation
exploration bonus that people use
empirically and this works kind of well
but it has
somewhat high variance so at some stage
like it fails to do a
do something and then it's like it fails
afterwards
and then we ran homer which is somehow
like quite stable is able to discover
um the right state space and and explore
all the time stuff so this i'm just
showing you the coverage of these
algorithms
so um so that's like sort of flavor of a
kind of thing that we're able to do in
the block mdp
land and um stepping back a bit
the black mdp i kind of like this model
because
like conceptually what we're doing is
we're saying here's this tabular problem
we know how to solve tabular
mdps for the most part but i'm going to
associate
like i'm going to attach like a complex
observation process with a hidden
tabular structure
so i'm like going to decouple the
dynamics of the world which are
relatively simple from an observation
process
which can be fairly complicated and
that's like a cool i think that's like a
cool way to think about how to develop
new algorithms for reinforcement
learning that have to use nonlinear
function approximation
so block mdp yeah we have to use
nonlinear function approximation here so
that's like
it's good it forces us to do something
hard
perhaps it's a good model for real
settings like navigation
uh and we have been able to develop some
algorithms that show that it's
statistically algorithmically tractable
on the other hand when you start playing
with these algorithms in practice
you start to get annoyed by the fact
that the latent space is discrete
because somewhere in your algorithm you
have to do some discretization
and this is not very gradient friendly
so it's like actually not that
compatible with deep learning
so that's something that like i found to
be a bit annoying and maybe a more minor
point is
like there's no reason to believe that
decodability is actually required as
long as you can
approximate the value functions and
policies from your observations
so that's like maybe something we'd like
to remove
okay so that's like that's like how i
got to this problem that i haven't told
you about yet
the other way you might arrive at this
problem is by just seeing what the rl
theory community has
done in the last two years which is like
study this linear function
approximation stuff like super intensely
and of course this is not like
um a new thing linear function
approximation reinforcement learning we
have all these classical results
um but in the last two years there's
just been like a uh
i don't know like a flood of activity in
this area and i'm
actually highlighting all the ones that
were presented in the rl theory seminar
um so if you're paying attention to rl
theory land
you must know about some of this stuff
and i i think this this stuff is like
super cool and i'm like learning so much
by reading these papers
um but then we started asking
you know so okay so in these papers what
are they doing they're going to use
like some they're going to use linear
functions of some given feature map
to approximate the value functions and
policies and
things like that and we started asking
like where do these features come from
so a very natural question is can we do
something to learn the features
so that we can apply these uh linear rl
methods that
that we've just developed in the last
couple years
and so that's what this talk is about
we're going to do provably efficient
future learning or representation
learning in perhaps the simplest model
in which we know linear function
approximation can work which is the low
rank mvp
um and so if you if you're a block mdp
enthusiast you can think about this as
how to do nonlinear function
approximation beyond this block model
and if you're a linear rl method linear
rl enthusiast you can think about
how to learn the features so that we can
do linear rl stuff afterwards
and yeah the key challenge is that
learning these features and exploration
are intertwined
and this is a bit complicated because
you can't use techniques like optimism
in the same way because
when you're doing non-linear function
approximation your function class does
not support the confidence intervals
that you might get from linear or
tabular function classes
so this is going to be the key challenge
um maybe now is a good time to stop if
there are any quick questions
okay sweet so i i know i haven't said
anything technical i will tell you
something
now okay so what is this model this is
the lowrance mdp
uh it has many names uh i like lowrance
mdp but
there's this factorized linear mdp
linear mdp all sorts of things
basically the dynamics which is this
like transition matrix t
factorize into two terms one is this
feature map five xa
and another is this embedding mu of x
prime
and the embedding dimension which is the
the dimensionality of the feature map
phi and the future map mu
is d which is going to be much much
smaller than the size of the state space
or the observation space
and we're going to actually think about
so this is like some structural
assumption about the way the world works
right and we're going to think about the
setting where you don't know this
feature map fee
but maybe like just i'll tell you a
little a couple structural things so
first of all the block mdp
is a low rank mdp so if you have a block
mdp it
you can write it as a lowering mdp where
in addition to this low rank
factorization
the right hand factor this mu matrix has
to be block diagonal after permutation
and this is just so that each
observation can only be generated by one
of these latent
ranks or factors or states so the
rank of the matrix is the number of
states in this problem
but of course you know this is a very
very strong additional assumption beyond
low rank so you can create these
problems it's like basically generic to
create a problem
where um the transition operator is low
rank but does not emit any non-trivial
block factorization
and another structural connection is
this um
this uh stochastic factorization that
comes from this paper by
andre barreto and doyna and joelle where
you
assume that both the phi matrix and the
mu matrix are row stochastic
so the features live on the simplex and
the rows of the mu matrix live on the
simplex
and this has a really nice
interpretation in terms of
sampling in terms of some latent
variable model so i'm at some state i'm
about to apply an action
the way i'm going to transition is i'm
first going to sample a latent variable
z
from this distribution 5 x a and i'm
going to sample the next state
from an emission distribution associated
with the latent variable z
so this is kind of like very close to
block mdp except that the latent
variables or the latent states are not
decodable
on the other hand it's not an hmm
because you don't have to remember the
history to
figure out what the distribution over
the next latent variable is going to be
so this is this model studied by bereto
precup and pinot
and they show that you know you can like
swap the factors and get very efficient
algorithms
and it's also an example that was
mentioned in um this paper by jin yang
guang and jordan
so that's just some like structural
stuff that you know this kind of a
tangent
um getting back to the problem at hand
we should maybe ask why should we study
this these low rank mvps and the first
point which i think probably all of you
know is that
this problem is tractable if the feature
map is known this is this really nice
result by uh
jin yang long and jordan they give this
algorithm optimistic least squares value
iteration that gets a you know square
root t type regret
when the feature map is known something
that um
i guess we kind of knew before is that
actually this problem is statistically
tractable
even if the feature map is not known so
the this lowrance mdp model has
bellman rank d bellman rank is this
concept that we came up with in this
in this paper um no matter what the
function class you're using is
and you can if you have a function class
of candidate embeddings that contain the
true one
then this algorithm olive has a sample
complexity that scales
like what i'm showing here and again
this this has this um
this uh log cardinality of phi
dependence over here which is sort of
what you would hope for
this is sort of allowing you to scale to
nonlinear function approximation
on the other hand olive is not
computationally efficient so the goal
for this project is to get a
computational efficient algorithm with a
similar guarantee to olive
and that's kind of what we do the only
so that's basically what we do there's
only one caveat which is
this thing here so we're going to make a
slightly stronger realizability
assumption
so we're going to assume that you have a
function class capital phi that contains
a true dynamic the true feature map phi
we're also going to assume you have a
function class capital upsilon that
contains the other factor
mu so this is going to be like a model
based realizability you have the full
transition operator
in your function class but this is a
relatively weak inductive bias
these things could be quite large
function classes
and we're also going to work in an
oracle computational model just like in
the homer
setting and we're going to assume you
can optimize and sample from these
things so you know when you take a phi
and a mu you get a transition operator
and you should be able to sample from it
that's what we're saying here and so
what we proved this is joint work with
alec agarwal sham kakade and one sun
we have this algorithm it's called
flambe it stands for future learning and
model based exploration
and we show that this algorithm can
learn a low rank mdp
so it has its own feature maps fi phi
hat and new hat
that uh gives you this kind of system
identification guarantee
so it's going to actually unif
universally approximate
the dynamics of the true world for any
role in policy and any time step
so this is you know the you take you
pick any role and policy you like you
pick any time step
you apply actions by following that
policy pi and you get to some state
xh and then you look at what your model
is going to predict
about the next state and what the true
transition operator predicts about the
next state
and you measure the total variation
distance and we're going to get this
accuracy epsilon for any policy and any
time step
and this is going to be good enough to
optimize any reward
okay and we can do this in a sample
complexity that scales polynomially in d
the number of actions the time horizon
the accuracy parameter
and the you know the statistical
complexity of the function classes
again this is like almost a standard
generalization argument so
you can scale this to non-linear
function classes with bounded metric
entropy
or stuff like that and you know maybe a
technical point is actually we've been
able to relax the reachability
restriction
that we had in the homer setting and
okay and the algorithm runs in
polynomial time in this oracle model
assuming you can optimize and sample
from these um these functions that you
have
let me just tell you some other random
facts um so
we actually do have a formal
representation learning guarantee
so we're going to learn a low rank mdp
m-hat which has features
phi hat and in this model for any reward
the optimal policy and q function will
be linear in our features
which means due to the total variation
guarantee that in the true
world a near optimal policy is going to
be linear in the learned features
so this is like you've actually learned
a representation fee hat that allows you
to approximate
all the things you might care about in
your true world
we're also because we have a model we're
able to do reward free learning kind of
like what emily talked about on
wednesday
so you can optimize any reward function
that's given to you like
in you can get programmatic access to
the reward function you can optimize any
such function with no further experience
from the environment
and we also have a version where you
don't have to sample from the model so
you can do some sort of like real world
planning
but it requires some slightly stronger
assumptions
okay so i want to tell you a little bit
about the algorithm and
we'll see how much of the proof we can
get to okay so the algorithm actually
conceptually i think it's quite simple
so you're just going to start with a
random policy and you're going to just
repeat this thing for many iterations
and in each iteration you're going to
use the previous policy that you have to
collect some data
so you're going to roll this policy is
going to you know recommend actions on
the basis of
states you're going to follow the first
h recommendations according to the
policy and then you're going to take the
h step random
and you're just going to terminate the
episode however you like
and what you're hoping for is that this
policy sort of covers the state space at
time
h so that you can learn the model
accurately
uniformly at time age but there's a
technical point in there we don't even
know how to measure coverage
but that's like sort of intuitively what
you're hoping for
and then you're going to just learn the
dynamics using the data that you just
collected
or using all the data that you have
and then maybe the the hard part is you
have to compute a new exploratory policy
that hopefully
gets you to some new place and so maybe
the picture
this is sort of not exactly the right
picture but maybe it's helpful
is you want road j minus one to cover
the state space at time
h so now when you take a random action
you'll be able to uniformly approximate
the dynamics
from time step h to h plus one
and actually you'll have like decent
coverage at time step h plus one up to a
factor of the number of actions a
and what you'd like to do in this um
when you compute an exploratory policy
is to sort of
shave off this factor of a again so
you'd like to say somehow road j
does not take the h to action randomly
but just gets it directly to
time step h one without paying this
uniform random action
so that's sort of what you're trying to
boost this coverage probability as you
go forward um okay and there's sort of
two questions we have to ask so one is
how do you learn the dynamics
and the other one is how to compute the
exploratory policy
so learning that the dynamics i think is
actually kind of cool this is not
something i just learned
this is some like classical results um
this is like
very classical in statistics world so
here's sort of what we're going to do
you're going to collect these triples
x h h 1 and you're just going to solve
the maximum likelihood problem so you're
just going to search
over your function classes for the pair
that maximizes the log probability of
the data
and something that was actually quite
surprising to me is that this actually
works
so this is like very classical but
here's a version from tongzhang
so if you assume realizability of the
dynamics
you can actually guarantee um that when
you solve the mle problem
you can accurately approximate the
transition operator in total variation
on the data distribution with which you
collected transitions okay
and the right hand side here is like
what you might expect from a standard
generalization argument
although this is not a standard
generalization argument there is
something
clever going on here okay so let's call
this thing
the error you know this is the point
wise error of the of the
transition operator when you are at
state xh and you apply action age
okay so you can also prove a martingale
version that's like just kind of
technical
um and now okay so what i want to do is
i sort of want to say that
this these exploratory policies so i've
i've written this so for all the
exploratory policies i've seen so far
i somehow want to be able to track if
these exploratory policies are covering
my state space
and so this is sort of where like the
first where we're going to use the
lowering mdp property in a very strong
way
and i guess the point is that there's
there's a lot of magic happening inside
this expectation
so how did you get to xhah
well you got to xh minus one a h minus
one
and then you applied a transition but
the transition is low rank
and so you should actually be able to
write this expectation in terms of the
future at the previous time
and now you're going to detect some
d-dimensional quantity in which you can
measure progress
so this is basically what we do that's
sort of like maybe the key idea
okay so i'm going to define these
covariances of my exploratory policies
so this is if i were to roll in with my
exploratory policy and look at the true
feature
at time step h and this is the
covariance of the true feature
basically rewriting this martingale
inequality i can get something that
looks like this
and so this is the error this is the
this is like when i wrote this as an
expectation one step backwards this is
the feature at the previous time
so now i'm writing this in terms of like
a d-dimensional euclidean norm
okay and and this is so now it's kind of
clear what you want to do you sort of
want to make sure that
your exploratory policies are have a
very large
you know covariance matrix at the
previous time and if that's the case
you'll be able to transfer to any other
policy so that that's maybe the key idea
um and so yeah this is this is the basic
property for any function f
and any policy pi the expectation of
f of x h when you roll in with policy pi
it can be written as a dimensional inner
product in the true future
where the first term depends on pi and
the second term actually does not it
just depends on f
and so this is basically what we're
going to do here okay so i think i'm
going to skip the next slide because
it's
perhaps the most technical one
yeah so basically what we do is we want
to sort of um maximize this we want
our policy row to sort of have good
quadratic form so that you're
gaining in the coverage the issue is
that you you don't actually know
um you don't actually know the features
so what you do is you plan
you you ask your exploratory policy to
have good coverage in your learned
features at
one time step even before and then this
will ensure that you have good coverage
and the true features
at the current time so that's sort of um
i'm gonna skip all this stuff okay um so
that's the basic idea
so you can you can use the feature map
at the previous time to measure your
your coverage and you can use your
learned feature map one time even before
as a potential function for you to find
an exploratory policy
and so what you can say somehow if um
maybe i should skip this
okay so so that's like sort of how the
proof goes i think the one key idea
somehow
even though you don't have the feature
map there it does exist a potential
function
which is the feature map of the previous
time and so now you can use this thing
to track your progress and measure
coverage and all these things
so i want to like return to this
conceptual point which is about like
how are we like able to do non-linear
function approximation in some sense
and basically what we're doing is we're
taking models that we know to be
tractable
and attaching a high dimensional
observation space and so we've done this
in a block mdp
where the model that we know to be
trackable is the tabular one we've also
done this in the low rank mdp where the
model
that we know to be tractable is the
linear mdp and
you know so we're able to get some
results where you don't know this latent
state but you can decode it
we're able to get some results where you
don't know the representation but you
can decode it
and there's still a bunch of other stuff
that we actually don't don't know so
there's a bunch of other settings that
we know to be statistically tractable
by computationally intractable and i
feel like this is like
maybe a general recipe for us to
discover new algorithmic principles
so you know you take your favorite mdp
problem or your rl problem that you know
to be tractable you attach
this like rich observation space and you
force yourself to use nonlinear function
approximation
and uh hopefully you can develop a new
algorithm that can solve that problem
um there's a bunch of open questions
here i like i feel like this is like
just sort of
maybe cracking the surface um you might
ask about the dependence on the number
of actions because in the linear mdp
setting you actually don't need to
depend on this
but this problem is kind of like it's
kind of like a sparse banded problem
where you
you should have to depend on the number
of actions um because there's like this
feature selection component which really
looks like
running the lasso or something like that
um sharp rates and regret yeah we have
no idea
um our bound is pretty bad but it is
polynomial
um and does it actually work well
the jury's out but we are trying it out
um so i'll just end with some links to
the papers
and thank everyone that's from left to
right alec
michael sham john dipendra and when
thanks a lot
thank you okay uh wow
the we're still i'm really good time and
we have a couple more minutes
are there any questions well
um maybe alex you can get set up if you
don't mind
oh there's a question oh go on what
oh there's one question in the chat in a
q a is the feature function
aims to truncate or concentrate the
large state space
yeah that's kind of right so the state
space is going to be really complicated
but somehow the all of the transition
dynamics are passing through this
d-dimensional bottleneck
so you can sort of ignore all this
spurious information about the state
except for the fact that you except for
these d bits
or d reels and that's going to
sort of it's like a compression operator
all right um could you unsure uh please
oh yeah sorry
thanks
hey any last questions um remember that
we'll have a discussion section in an
hour
question section uh i can uh ask it
thank you okay well thank you again
option
and our next speaker is alex lipkins
also